but jack i just need to um start things
off by letting you know that don't worry
carl and liz are totally having your
back during these interviews
oh no no
oh great cool totally one
oh my gosh i am so excited for season
two because you guys left us off on
such a big cliffhanger that really
deviated from the graphic novels
carl let's dive right into butcher so
what's your big plan
we'll take them here
can i get my wife back
we're in of course we're in
yeah uh when we meet butcher at the
beginning of season
2 upon the back of that revelation
season 1
he's a lot more desperate he's
vulnerable
dangerous and he needs the boys in order
to help him
find his wife and everything er
is viewed through that lens and you know
really the question is how far is billy
butcher
willing to go uh in order to get his
wife back and
so it and sort of the journey really
leads him on a
very deep and personal journey that sort
of forces butcher to take a good
cold hard look in the mirror yeah i feel
like if we were to continue with
butcher's
spice boys analogy he's like scary as
hell spice right now but last
is like the spice that holds everyone
together
les is possible mm is posh spice for
sure you know
meticulous and clean and washing the
hands
kiwi would be baby spice and freshly
ginger and obviously
kimiko is sporty spice totally ain't you
twice lucky that i've shown up
you guys get to get away with so much on
this show
i'll hail amazon for the things you guys
get to do
uh was there ever a moment in season two
when you looked around you're like i
cannot believe this is happening
yeah i think probably that point where
we are uh
sitting deep inside a sperm whale uh
covered in blood and guts that i'm like
okay this is something new for the
history of television
um this will will go down in the anals
of history is
uh one of those shows
is constantly giving us material that
you know we never thought that would
ever end up
on anybody's screen but welcome to the
boys
i'd say eric kripke kicked our
asses seat into like kicked our asses
like
this was one of those seasons where i
went home you're an old
like i
[Laughter]
right this season has given jack quaid
a uh now lifelong fear of boats
right turkey put him in a speedboat that
i was driving
and uh and let me tell you we were going
fast we were jumping waves and
you know jack's raised in hollywood i
don't know if they ever been on the
waterf
a boat that's airborne um
you know he had a safety word that he
had to scream out if he ever felt unsafe
and it was carl and apparently he was
like i was
you know driving along and we're jumping
waves and and he was going carl carl
carl
i couldn't see his face because he's
facing forward and i couldn't hear him
because there was a helicopter
shooting us and the sound of the engine
but i remember at the end one
of one run looking over at laz and he
was fine to look over at jack and he is
white as a sheet and and i thought he
was just like
seasick or something but no he's
actually in
mortal fear of his very life and
so he's like i'm tapping out okay you
guys go ahead you guys go ahead i'm good
i got another jack story so uh
in season two uh we introduced terror
carl's uh well butcher's dog yeah and uh
terror uh the real dog's name is bentley
and you can follow him
on instagram he has his own instagram
page bentley alexander
um he was casted because he's very
popular on youtube from his something
videos so he was casted off of youtube
he humps this this pink pig incessantly
non-stop and that's his hump pig well
uh in the script he's supposed to be
humping a parrot
and so jack and i get on set we see this
cute little dog we're playing with him
jack picks up this pig and he's like
playing with the pig
and he's tossing it around and he's
heading it and he's hugging
he's like snuggling it up to his face i
mean he's got it in his face
he's like doing everything with the pig
and then
right before we shoot jack's like no no
wait wait wait wait we need the parrot
and they're like what parrot he's like
well the parrot that he's supposed to
hump on
they're like oh you know what he
wouldn't hump the parrot
but so we just decided to bring his pig
because
that's his hump toy and jack's like
witch pig they're like
the pig that you're holding right now
jack was sitting there like he's just
completely immersed
himself with this pig and he's looking
at his hands and he's going oh my god i
thought that was earwax
i can't even ask follow-up questions to
that because i know that we're way out
of time but
thank you so much love for that i cannot
wait
to go talk to jack right now be like
they were just dunking on you the whole
time
and right now we're in a little bit of
trouble
we have so much to talk about but jack i
just need to um
start things off by letting you know
that don't worry carl and laz
are totally having your back during
these interviews oh no
no don't worry i don't know anything
about
what really happened on the boat or the
stuffed pig
or the fact that for baby spice
i'm okay being baby spice first of all
let me just say that on the record
all good with that i just know that on
that end of the interview spectrum they
are just
imagining me that's every day on set
it's just constant roasting but it's an
honor because they're both
incredible of course of course and i
just it's my life now so sure
you'll love it i won't love it i never
love it never
love it
you